E
TO CROSS COUNTRY BACK LIVE IN
NEW YORK CITY AND TONIGHT WE
BEGIN IN NEW ORLEANS.
AMERICA'S MURDER CAPITAL WE'VE
REPORTED ON CROSS COUNTRY ABOUT
SHOCKING SURGE AND HOMICIDES,
THEY'RE UP 141.FROM BACK IN
2019.
THE FUN LOVING ATMOSPHERE OF THE
BIG EASY NIEWRNGD CLOUD OF
VIOLENCE AND THIS WEEK, THE
POLICE SUPERINTENDENT ANNOUNCE
HIS RESIGNATION AS OFFICERS
LEAVE THE FORCE IN DROVES.
SO IN A CROSS COUNTRY
INVESTIGATION, WE'VE GOT AHOLD
OF HUNDREDS OF DOCUMENTS THAT
EXIT SURVEYS OF THOSE IN THE NEW
ORLEANS POLICE DEPARTMENT.
THOSE OFFICERS THAT LEFT THE
DEPARTMENT AND WE INTOAK SPOKE
WITH THE PEOPLE OF NEW ORLEANS
TO GET TO THE BOTTOM OF WHAT'S
GOING SO WRONG.
HERE'S A BIT OF WHAT WE FOUND.
WATCH.
NEW ORLEANS LOUISIANA, MURDER
CAPITOL OF THE UNITED STATES BUT
THE CITY PROBLEM RUN DEEPER THAN
THAT AND HAVE BEEN PLAGUING BIG
EASY FOR YEARS.
AMERICA'S POLICE OFFICERS ARE
SWORN TO SERVE AND PROTECT THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
BUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THEY
AREN'T GIVEN RESOURCES THEY NEED
TO DO THEIR JOBS >> DO I FEEL
SAFE?
HELL NO I DON'T FEEL SAFE.
>> WHEN I'M SEEING POLICE CARS
PARKED BUT DON'T SEE OFFICERS
THEMSELVES BUT THEY HAVE IT IN
THE AREA JUST FOR, YOU KNOW,
SHOW.
WHEN YOU CALL 9-1-1, YOU HAVE TO
WAIT HOURS FOR POLICE TO SHOW NO
MATTER WHAT THE SITUATION.
THEY'VE TOLD EVERYBODY THIS.
THEY WENT ON THE NEWS THAT WE
HAVE SLOWEST RESPONSE TIME IN
THE COUNTRY BASICALLY AND
SOMEONE BREAKS IN THE HOG AND
POLICE MIGHT NOT SHOW UP FOR TWO
HOURS THAT TELLS CRIMINALS I
DON'T HAVE TO RUN SO FAST.
FACING CATASTROPHIC POLICE
SHORTAGE AND SENGDZING
SHOCKWAVES THROW THE CITY AND
OFFICERS LEAVING FORCE IN DROVES
AND INTERNAL RECORDS OBTAINED BY
CROSS COUNTRY REVEAL WHAT'S
CAUSING THIS MASS EXODUS ALMOST
AT 100 FROM THE START OF 2022
THROUGH JULY, NEARLY 60% OF
OFFICERS RAIDED DEPARTMENTS
WORKING CONDITIONS NEGATIVELY.
AND OVER HALF WERE NOT SATISFIED
WITH MANAGEMENT WILLINGNESS TO
MAKE CHANGES.
BUT IT IS NOT JUST OUTDATED
EQUIPMENT AND A LOW SALARY
THAT'S PUT IN INNOCENT LIVES AT
RISK.
MULTIPLE OFFICERS CLAIMANT
DEPARTMENT WILL E THROUGH ITS
WORKERS UNDER BUS AND REFUSE TO
DEFEND THEM WHEN PUSH COME TO
SHOVE.
WHEN ASKED WHAT THE DEPARTMENT
COULD DO TO KEEP OFFICERS FROM
LEAVING FORCE ONE RETIRING COP
KEPT IT SIMPLE ALL THEY WANT IS
MORE EMPHASIS ON CRIME FIGHTING.
THESE PEOPLE AREN'T LEAVING
BECAUSE PAY IS GOOD.
THEY'RE NOT LEAVING BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A FUN DAY AT WORK THEY'RE
LEAVING BECAUSE JOB SUCKS THEY
DON'T GET PAID OR RESPECTS AND
NOBODY WANTS TO DO IT.
>> YOU DESCROANT TO LITERALLY
WALK STREETS BUT JUST DRIVE
AROUND THE NEIGHBORHOODS.
YOU KNOW LET US SEE THAT THERE'S
A PRESENCE.
AND YOU DON'T REALLY SEE THAT.
FIGURE OUT WHAT'S NEEDED AND
WHAT NEEDS TO BE CHANGED.
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S LAWS OR
SYSTEM